what else you guys been up to man uh you
just came back from a little vacation
Italy right I went to Italy it was fun
yeah uh why why did you you just wanted
to go to Italy or well yeah because I
you know the rest of our year is gonna
be pretty rammed uh and I was gonna go
pretty hard with work anyway and I
thought you know in [__] it I'll take a
little time off I'll spend a week I'll
go to Italy and I'll just chill out
literally do nothing like do no work
which is crazy
imagine you doing no work how dare you
yeah so I just went to Italy I run to
the car and then drove around and ate
food all day dude I sound six coffee
game is unimaginable in Italy wait Which
part of Italy where is north or south uh
North North okay I drove around the
north
um I just basically went to I was like I
like this food where does it originate
from in Italy and that's why I went
there so like I love like Genovese
Genovese sauce yeah yeah yeah I love
that so I was like oh my go to Genova
because that's where it's from and I had
like just an ungodly amount of pesto it
was so [__] good dude it was oh my
God it's unreal uh I went to Bologna
bologna
which you know I wasn't a big fan of
bolognese sauce but they do it and it
was UN unreal how hard they do you got a
dude it's dude like I I you know I've
been to Italy before so I knew the pasta
was good but I just don't remember it
being that good it was like what do you
mean like I think I was like I was like
16 17 18. I didn't appreciate it yeah
after eating pasta a lot in Japan I'm
like you know and I thought it was
pretty good here yeah I thought it was
all right and then go to Italy I'm like
it's like the kindergarteners versus the
pros it's not even like that I don't
know how it's just flower like how is
this so different like this is crazy but
like every you know and that pastors
I've just never even heard of yeah what
the [__] is this now like actually yeah
it's a shack inverted of pasture and we
stop it when I'm like what okay yeah
give me that hell yeah
um and and like like I said like the
coffee
is unreal how much coffee did you have
yeah like eight espressos a day just
because like hate Expo oh my gosh just
because like dude you go anywhere and
people offer you espressos it's so
bizarre right so like Conor's like why
is my resting heart better yeah for sure
I had the lowest heart rate in Italy
like yeah
so I you know I was driving and like the
first areas I drove around like I knew
the car but then after that it was kind
of annoying to have a car so I I ran
yeah I just got the trains because it
was pretty good
uh super annoying you couldn't really
like go around you had to go back into
like Milan and then go back right so I
was just like [__] this um so I drove
the first part
you know where I went to actually
oh
you know I went to and I guess this all
started because of you is that you
remember you bought us the barolo wine
yeah I went to barolo oh yeah oh [__] so
I I went to bed yeah dude it was awesome
yeah so Brawler's such a cooler I'm
talking like [__] son of that guy
especially just like this really like
picturesque sprawling Hills really
beautiful I rented a Vesper as well oh
now we're talking now we're talking that
was super high yeah like dude Italians
just also like okay there's so much to
talk about Italians just don't give a
[__] full stop ever uh I go to rental
dude just didn't ask me for anything he
was just like come back in like a few
hours and then I was like you need to
see my driving license he's like oh yeah
yeah yeah and I was like oh thanks oh
yeah I do and he was like oh just give
me 50 euros then come back later I'm
like all right okay everyone was just
super chill about everything
um but yeah I know like so as I was
saying coffee everywhere like I got on
this train and I I booked like I don't
know like a the nicer version of the the
train carriage or whatever right and I
sit down at this train I get on this guy
comes up to me he's like hey do you want
an espresso and I was like yeah
like the guy who works out I was like oh
oh yeah sure okay I'll take an espresso
Connor can never say no to Expresso that
was my I was it was like supersized me
but for espressos it was like my rules I
wasn't allowed to say no to any
espressos yeah if someone offers me a
coffee good on the train though super
good because really dude this is the
thing that I learned about Italy it
doesn't matter how dog [__] the area or
the building or whatever your place is
in it could be like their most run down
like everything had an espresso machine
in it and a good one like I'm convinced
people who are like like can't afford
their rent or whatever they're like damn
I'm homeless but I'm not an animal holds
holds espresso machine you know what I
mean like it's like I went so then I
went on the train as well
and I went to like the the food
compartment where you can get food it
was Barren there was nothing it was like
two bags of crisps but of course there
was just a giant one of those really
massive espresso yeah they're like the
and they're everywhere and I'm like oh
I'm like can I get a cappuccino and he's
like of course it makes me cappuccino
every cappuccino was like one Euro as
well I was like this is [__] up this
is so cheap everywhere it makes coffee
amazing like everywhere everywhere does
the Italian government just give each
new resident of Italy just like an
espresso yeah it's like subsidized yeah
it comes with every house like welcome
to the country here's your espresso
there's gonna be something I'm missing
because like those machines are
expensive but they're everywhere
everyone has one
um and it's so good because some of the
taxpayer money is going yeah like I
landed I landed in the in the I got the
airport I stayed at the airport hotel
like one nearby and I I sang this hotel
and I wake up and I go to the breakfast
and I was kind of this I was like I'm
not gonna lie it's kind of heartbroken
because I went for the breakfast yeah
and it was like it's an American coffee
and I was just in this like just Jog and
I was like so I pour it and I stopped
drinking because I need coffee yeah and
then I see people getting cappuccinos
I'm like oh [__] they're they're talking
salvation I'm like what they're like oh
they're just to order [__] I'm an idiot
so then I had to I was like oh I [__]
poured this thing no one of my coffees
I've wasted it yeah it was inside my
eight a day
that was wasted
like on an American coffee oh it's so
good it was just like the coffee the
coffee game in Italy is just the best
I've ever had in my life it's just the
the the the amount that everyone drinks
and as well as like everyone just cares
there's no like chains anywhere it's all
just like everyone just knows how to
make good coffee and there's good I
didn't have to go to a single Starbucks
no actually there is a Starbucks
Roastery like one of the reserved ones
the fancy ones in Milan which I checked
out so I was like I wonder what
Starbucks looks like in Italy because
it's gonna be like it's gonna be good it
has to be because you're in Italy
that's like saying McDonald's has to be
good in America right surely surely yeah
because I literally have like an hour to
kill and I was like yeah it's right next
to where I was staying I was like oh
[__] it I'm gonna have a look and then I
went to the uh because they had like the
they do alcohol drinks in that Starbucks
yes right I suppose this is Europe yeah
yeah I had the like the espresso Martini
that they made with olive oil and [__]
it was [__] bomb it was so good oh
God damn dude but yeah I Pastor every
single day for lunch and dinner
um because I don't know I haven't
checked
it's like dude you you I I remember this
as well but like Chinese eat a lot or at
least
you go to the the every dinner they have
the like first course which is like
normally like just pasta and then you
get a Mane but the pasta is like the
size of what I would consider to be a
main yeah so normally I'm eating just
two main dishes in a [__] starter
every night I'm like dying but it's so
good that I can't stop and every night I
was just in pain like oh I can't do it
again proceeds to immediately do it
again yeah but it's so good
um and man Italy is just like I just
felt like when I was there I was like
man this is just Southeast Asia
uh there's [__] mopeds everywhere the
mopeds run Italy like they were just
[__] everywhere like Vespers yeah and
there was no parking for like bicycles
only parking for like Vespers and it was
just again everywhere there's so many of
them right you reminded me of when I was
in Thailand and then also everyone's
like loud very loud uh you go to like a
nice family restaurant and everyone is
it's like a different it's like
enthusiastic right I wouldn't say loud
as an like obnoxious more like
everyone's with their family they are
very very loud how's the driving over
there that's the real test yeah they're
insane they just they're not they don't
they don't give a [__] I'm pretty sure
the rules are a suggestion okay okay
because like I think they think they
have like an Autobahn but they I don't
know if they realize there is a speed
limit on it because I was going the
speed limit and I was the slowest person
on the road yeah
um
dude I like no one indicates ever okay
feeling at home I'm not feeling at home
all right yeah you know what I mean like
yeah I'm here I'm like I'm just in
Southeast Asia but in Europe and it's
hot you know uh the only thing it's
missing is like super spicy food yeah
but like it was yeah it just reminded me
so much of Southeast hello my fellow
Italians you know yeah
no no no like I've always wanted to go
to Italy anyway I I kick myself that I
never went to Italy when I actually
lived in [__] Europe uh but it's just
the [__] thing grass is greener on
the other side the problem for you is
that you have to eat the crust
here's the thing the crusts I can eat
the crust if the crust is good yeah okay
you know but 90 of the times if you are
in a [__] party and you order across
from like Pizza Hut or Domino's I'm like
nah nah this is this is not good crust
right but if it's like fresh Italian
pizza I don't like pizza wants I should
pass it all the time I mean I I mean I
would have a lot of pasta as well yeah
it's so good and it's so like varied
right like yeah I love pizza but yeah
pasta definitely has more variety for
sure yeah yeah there's way more types of
pasta I found as opposed to I mean like
pizza is very varied but you know it's
yeah it's some [__] Lighthouse I
heard I I remember as well when I went
to North Italy the seafood there was
also really fun yeah yeah I had a lot of
seafood uh whenever there's fish on the
menu I would just order it oh the
seafood yeah it's really good so good
grilled fish was so good oh they're big
fish too
um God you're getting me hungry man
you're getting me so hungry it's very
good yeah I think yeah I mean privileged
very very privileged to be able to go
there and enjoy it oh it was [__]
bomb uh yeah it was great I think
there's nothing I don't really have much
to say about it yeah when when was the
last time you went to Italy before like
going by this time
I think I skied over from France and
spent like a day
skied over and you can ski oh yeah I'm
from France to Italy okay some of the
things uh
um ski slopes yeah the last time I went
but I think the last time I actually
went to Italy was I think I went skiing
there right I think touring or something
when I was younger but again I was like
I was like 17 16. I didn't you know I
was just like
you know you when you're at that age
you're like I just want to play DS
back I didn't appreciate the food why
why aren't we going forward to leave for
our tour man
there's no Italians watch us no Italians
watching us God damn it come on guys